[Música]
buenas tardes bueno voy a contaros un
poquito mi historia de vida y haber si
os hago entender todo lo que yo he
aprendido a lo largo de este tiempo
primero me gustaría lanzar os unas
preguntas para que podamos reflexionar
sobre ellas la primera es que cosas
queréis hacer
que no estáis sabiendo que no se atreve
y saber qué cosas estáis posponiendo que
no deberíais de posponer y quizás la más
importante creéis que podéis conseguir a
ver esas cosas
bueno me presento aunque ya me ha
presentado soy sarah andrés soy
profesora de educación primaria y ahora
soy atleta paralímpica y bueno os cuento
un poquito como he llegado a ser atleta
paralímpica y es que en 2011 con tan
solo 25 años una vida pues pues a
empezar digamos ya trabajaba salía
entraba con mis amigos en ese momento
que es idílico para todos los para todas
las personas cuando empiezas la vida
adulta digamos pues en ese momento perdí
mis pies
así de repente de la noche a la mañana
bueno imaginaos me sentí abatida me
sentí triste desubicada desolada no
sabía muy bien que iba a ser de mi vida
no tenía claro hacia dónde iba a tirar
si lo podía superar
fue muy difícil lo primero que cambió
fue mi físico claro de repente tenía
pies y al día siguiente ya no y lo
segundo que cambió fue mi pensamiento y
con ello me actitud y me voy y mi
voluntad
mi vida cambió aún así cambio a mejor os
puedo decir y aprendí tres cosas que os
quiero trasladar que os quiero
pues enseñar tres cosas que aprendí de
aceptar superar y sobrepasar los límites
y estas tres cosas son la voluntad el
esfuerzo y el positivismo no nos
engañemos hay cosas que no se pueden
cambiar como la vida la muerte no es una
realidad
es así pero si nos fijamos en las cosas
del día a día en esos pequeños retos en
esas dificultades todas esas cosas se
muestran alcanzables para todos los que
nos lo propongamos
con voluntad que es la voluntad bueno
para mí la voluntad es tener ganas de
cambiar es tener ganas de transformar de
crear de hacer algo y en mi caso
era ir a unos juegos paralímpicos y
están los paralímpicos de río de janeiro
me sentía entusiasmada con ese reto tan
inmenso imposible pero que a la vez al
ser tan difícil me daba más fuerza de
poder conseguirlo
vosotros que quereis conseguir en
vuestras vidas
qué cosas queréis cambiar en vuestras
vidas pensando
al principio no fue nada fácil estoy
muchos meses con un duelo o gestionando
lo que me había ocurrido estuve mucho
tiempo triste con la ayuda con los
médicos todo había cambiado se habían
traspasado digamos los límites de lo
natural no de lo convencional si era una
chica con vida es que ya no tenía pies
eso era posible
me pregunte en ese momento es posible
esto que estoy viviendo y sin embargo la
respuesta es que sí que sí lo era
curiosamente
la verdad es que
hay muchas historias que contar mucho
proceso que pase pero gracias a eso a lo
que me ocurrió soy la persona que soy
ahora y hay que estar agradecido de las
cosas que no para en que nos pasan ahora
veréis por qué
bueno las ganas que yo tenía en mi mente
era de ir a unos juegos paralímpicos
pero es verdad que al principio estuve
en nueve meses en una silla de ruedas no
fue nada fácil tenía todo obstáculos y
límites primero los límites físicos pues
no podía salir sola a la calle porque
bueno había unas barreras en los
bordillos del asfalto en las aceras no
están acondicionadas a veces no podía ir
ni siquiera al baño los baños no estaban
adaptados no cabía la silla en mi casa
no era capaz de un vaso de la
estantería de la cocina no llegaba no
alcanzaba no estaba a mi altura bueno
esos límites físicos se fueron poco a
poco aceptando y superando gracias a la
habilidad la destreza que cogí con la
silla a la fuerza en vez de intentar
cogerlo con la mano pues ya me podía
levantar y me podía poner sobre la silla
y alcanzaba o cada vez tenía más fuerza
y entonces podía andar más más tiempo
con la silla
y lo supere en el momento en que
conseguí las prótesis de andar estas que
llevo me puse otra vez a la altura
he vuelto a la vida no he vuelto a la
altura que antes tenía ha vuelto a ser
como los demás no sin dolor no sin
sufrimiento no sin muchas horas de
entrenamiento no de exponerlas y ya lo
sobrepase esos límites cuando decidí
empezar a correr
estos son los límites físicos pero es
que hay unos límites que son los
psicológicos que cuáles son estos pues
son las ideas preconcebidas son los
miedos qué miedos tenéis vosotros que
nos nos están ayudando a avanzar os
están impidiendo avanzar
los míos eran los siguientes yo tenía
amigos bueno primero la incertidumbre de
qué vida me tocaría no después que vida
me esperaba después del miedo a las
miradas de los demás a que ya no me
mirarán como siempre me mirarán como un
raro tenía miedo a no poder salir
a la calle o salir con los amigos ir a
una discoteca y no ligar para que nadie
me quisiera tenía incluso miedo de no
poder volver a ponerme una falda corta o
unos pantalones bueno pues con ayuda del
psicólogo los psicólogos de la voluntad
que le puse bueno veréis ahora no enseño
las prótesis sin ningún problema primero
porque me encantan y es lo que hay me
gustan los pies protésicos que llevo y
segundo también lo hago por una razón
porque cuando vosotros me veis también
estáis rompiendo vuestros propios
límites
y la segunda el esfuerzo bueno cuando
tenemos esa idea clara ese plan ese
deseo ese sueño lo único que tenemos que
hacer es dar los pasos adecuados en la
consecución de esa meta y esto no es
fácil y no viene de un día a otro no
hay un tiempo y un esfuerzo una
constancia tiempo de pensar cómo lo voy
a lograr qué pasos tengo que hacer y una
constancia una perseverancia día a día
para conseguirlo
en mi caso bueno pues desde el primer
momento que me puse las prótesis y como
os decía antes
bueno pues sufría muchos dolores esto
vapor
digamos por succión y entonces te
aprieta la pierna y al principio no
aguantaba nada ni un minuto tenía las
piernas moradas porque la circulación no
va bien después dos minutos tres minutos
así poquito a poco al principio andaba
con dos muletas luego con una y al final
salía a la calle de mi casa y me
agarraba la barandilla que hay al lado y
va poco a poco agarrándome la farola oa
la gente que veía bueno pues así
conseguí aguantar todo un día con las
prótesis una vez que aguante todo el día
que las prótesis pensé quiero dar un
paso más
quiero aprender a correr y lo mismo paso
el mismo proceso que fue tan difícil
para andar también lo fue para correr me
impuse las prótesis no aguantaba el
dolor era insoportable el impacto no
estamos acostumbrados a que todo tu peso
recaiga en la rodilla es muy fuerte y
aparte es que es volverá a correr
aprender como un bebé realmente que no
sabe correr y aprende los primeros pasos
había veces que iba sola otras veces iba
con amigos que me sujetaban
me caía
y aguantaba el entrenamiento por 5
minutos
pero poco a poco con esa perseverancia
cada vez más entrenaba un día a la
semana dos días a la semana tres y hasta
hoy en día que entreno todos los días de
la semana cuatro horas al día y después
estoy casi 24 horas con las prótesis
puestas
esa es la el esfuerzo la perseverancia
por conseguir tu sueño pero no solo el
esfuerzo es físico como os he contado
sino también mental y psicológico y es
que yo en el momento en que pensé que
quería ir a los juegos paralímpicos de
río de janeiro no había ni un solo día
que no pensase que no visualizarse esa
idea bueno de hecho es que me imaginaba
entrando en el estadio me imaginaba la
pista el tartán mis contrincantes al
lado dichos que me imaginaba el corazón
excitado incluso las gotas de sudor
hasta ese punto de detalle yo imaginaba
y deseaba ese reto
bueno y es más en la ducha mientras me
duchaba me recitaba un poco me recitaba
un discurso de agradecimiento porque yo
pensaba que iba a ganar una medalla y
entonces me lo decía sí sí pero es que
me despertaba ya arrugada de esa
ensoñación a las manos llevaría y media
hora pero es que todos los días hacía
eso
y me creáis o no creerme por favor es
que funciona funciona a creer en tus
sueños funciona creer en ti mismo
funciona que creáis en vosotros mismos
y por último el positivismo el último
pero para mí el más importante ser
positivo no nos vamos a engañar nos
engañes en la vida nos van a pasar cosas
buenas y cosas malas si cosas malas
aceptarlo
asumirlo esta premisa es así hay gente
que vive pensando que siempre le van a
pasar cosas buenas pues no sé yo no
conozco a ninguna persona que tenga esa
experiencia de vida siempre te pasan
cosas malas oa ti oa tu entorno a tus
familiares o en el trabajo con tu pareja
siempre hay cosas malas entonces hay que
saber que esto nos puede ocurrir
hay que asumirlo y no hay que
preguntarse por qué a mí que lo hacemos
mucho somos un poco víctimas y porque me
ha tocado a mí no la pregunta correcta
es la pregunta que me tengo que hacer es
como respondo yo a este mal golpe que me
ha dado la vida
este mal golpe que sabía que me podía
tocar por probabilidad y por que no soy
invencible
de hecho
sí no fijaos en mí
con este golpe
que me ha dado la vida he encontrado
detrás cosas maravillosas he aprendido a
disfrutar la vida
he aprendido y tengo las ganas de
superarme día a día y ahora soy atleta
paralímpica
en este momento de mi vida el deporte ha
encontrado un hueco que de otra manera
no hubiera sido posible detrás de esas
dificultades que soportamos detrás de
sus malos golpes siempre hay cosas
maravillosas o cosas positivas que
aprender y es que si el esfuerzo y la
voluntad anteriormente que hemos puesto
no no funciona no conseguimos ese reto
no conseguimos ese proyecto que tenemos
en mente es ahí donde el positivismo
juega un papel muy importante tenemos
que ver por qué no ha salido es que a lo
mejor no he puesto suficiente y voluntad
es que a lo mejor 9 puesto suficiente
esfuerzo o es que llámalo el destino hay
cosas que tienen que ocurrir y os voy a
dar un ejemplo de esto nos remontamos al
2015 un año antes de río janeiro yo con
voluntad con esfuerzo entrenando todos
los días visualizando y vamos todos los
días entrenando y poniendo ahí la carne
en el asador
bueno pues un día en el entreno se me
cae una gotita por la por la cara y me
llega hasta el cuello
entonces me la quito y me noto un bulto
hoy al médico y me dice que tengo cáncer
de tiroides
imaginaos todos los sueños que tenía se
paralizaron por completo yo había puesto
mucha voluntad yo había puesto mucho
esfuerzo entrenando pero estaba claro
que en ese momento no tenía que hacer mi
sueño tenía que esperar bueno el
positivismo que tuve en ese tiempo que
seguí pensando que era capaz y que podía
y sobre todo centrada en mi salud en que
seguramente iba a conseguir salir de esa
enfermedad y pensando sobre todo en qué
bueno es cáncer de tiroides se puede
operar me lo quitan tengo que llevar una
medicación toda mi vida bueno vale ya
está podría haber sido peor si pues
entonces tengo que estar contenta pero
estar muy contenta de lo que me ha
pasado y hacer la lectura positiva de
eso bueno en ese tiempo estuve desde
septiembre hasta abril de baja y en ese
tiempo no deje de visualizar mi sueño no
deje de esforzarme y no deje de tener
esa voluntad pues está ahí y es más es
que conseguí estando de baja las
prótesis que necesitaba
para correr para ser velocista convencía
a la empresa que me esponsorizará cuando
estaba en el hospital no se lo conté a
nadie también es verdad pero bueno yo
hice hay un poco de estrategia y las
conseguí bueno pues en abril volví con
las mismas ganas de entrenar y tenía
tres meses para conseguir la marca
el último día el campeonato de españa el
último día que podía conseguir la marca
conseguir la marca y dos meses después
me vi desfilando en el estadio maracaná
representando a españa en los juegos
olímpicos de río de janeiro alucinante
que hacía no me lo puedo creer esto es
una pasada esto es un regalo a toda esa
voluntad de ese esfuerzo y ese
positivismo que de quinta del mundo
quizás si no hubiera tenido cáncer
podría haber sido tercera no se segunda
siendo muy optimista no lo sé
el caso es que en ese momento no tenía
que ser y yo ya estaba contenta porque
mi objetivo mi sueño era llegar a los
juegos así que con eso ya estaba súper
satisfecha al año siguiente con más
voluntad más esfuerzo conseguir al
mundial de londres 2017 y fui doble
medallista de bronce del 400 en el 200
y este año he batido el récord de salto
de longitud de mi categoría y estoy
visualizando con la misma voluntad con
el mismo esfuerzo
tokio 2020 de la misma manera que vi río
así que no os rindáis nunca pase lo que
pase
gracias a mi experiencia he podido
conocer he podido aprender cosas que muy
poca gente sabe y es que los límites se
pueden aceptar los límites se pueden
superar los límites se pueden sobrepasar
y solo aquel que se atreva a ir más allá
va a descubrir que detrás hay cosas
maravillosas y extraordinarias y yo os
pregunto ahora creéis que tenéis límites
yo pienso que no los tenéis pero yo creo
que pensáis que los tenéis pero no los
tenéis
porque los límites solo existen en
nuestra cabeza solo existen en nuestras
ideas nuestros pensamientos los creamos
nosotros
y si yo lo he conseguido vosotros
también lo podéis conseguir así que os
animo a que sobre paséis vuestros
límites muchas gracias
[Aplausos]